well some of us i'm speaking for myself
here take the cheat way out of holiday
wrapping by putting every gift in a bag
but here to help me and save the
holidays is our friend brooke fritz from
clover and stem hi bro hi jillian how
are you good happy holidays youtube
merry christmas you always bring the
best displays this one is extra festive
we're talking all things holiday
wrapping did you wrap everything on the
table yes so there are multiple ways you
can wrap you don't always have to have
wrapping paper but i wanted to start off
because i have the best wrapping paper
idea ever okay let's see it and it's
this one i made for you oh my gosh with
my face on it you guys look at it so i
took jillian's face and i i took it off
her social media page and we just
downloaded it on the computer and then
printed it off on copy paper at the
store what a brilliant idea yeah i love
this oh my gosh
i'm going to get this from you and i'm
just going to give it to all my family
so they just have my face on all their i
brought you extra just in case you
thought you might want to do that what
is an idea for pets or babies or
literally anything you want you can
customize it yeah would be so fun this
is my favorite thing i don't even care
what's inside
what a great idea okay let's talk
through some other tips that you have
while i'm just admiring this
so you don't always have to wrap your
gifts you can use your gift as a wrap so
over here we have a tray with pasta and
pasta sauce and i took a kitchen towel
and we wrapped
that up around it and put a christmas
ornament on there and so you don't
always have to have paper to wrap or a
box you can just use your gift to wrap
and the same goes with this
cheese board there we did that just with
the simple little
bow yeah a little greenery and i'm
looking at everything you have here this
is just kind of some brown paper are
those stamps or what you add on there no
okay so instead of going to the grocery
store and getting your plastic bags
asked for brown paper bags so when i was
a kid we used to wrap our books i think
you're too young
so we would wrap our books it's kind of
the same idea and so you can do that
with your kids have them help you wrap
it doesn't have to be professional it's
just about making memories and let them
color on them and you can write people's
name on them and that's okay okay and i
see a bag over here so you're saying
that's okay once in a while yeah once a
while it does not all the time but the
tip for that is is
not to cram your tissue paper in the bag
make it light and airy and fluffy look
it's like a floral arrangement it's so
perfect
okay well you're going to put my skills
to the test yeah it's going to be really
embarrassing but hey i love your brook
so like you showed me how to do it so
the biggest craze on social media right
now is this wrapping technique okay
let's see so i don't worry i already
started it for you like my heart's
beating up okay
so i cut the paper and first things
first is you're gonna roll fold it down
over okay and then you fold it so it's
triangles here and then you fold okay
okay now i got you to the next step and
you're just going to fold here okay
both sides you got it jillian i believe
in you thank you yeah
okay so you pulled it and now fold the
end just as if you were
doing a regular package okay a regular
package here regular package on the
bottom okay
okay i'll help you
you're doing amazing okay here we go you
can't mess up anything you do will be
fabulous and we're just taking it down
down and there you have the latest trend
it's a pocket i got you some greenery
right there and a candy cane and a candy
cane on brookie did make this really
easy on me so you can just stick it
stick it in what a great tip oh my gosh
bro thank you so much you're welcome if
you guys want more tips or just to look
at pretty photos go follow clover and
stem on social media she has all the
good stuff and